hello everybody my name is Mark varn
welcome back to let's play the witches
house now as you can tell that I'm in
some place different than where I
normally record because I am still in
South Carolina I've officially run out
of videos that I've pre-recorded back in
my apartment in Cincinnati so we will
move forward with this story without
interruption hopefully because Daniel
when Ryan McGee
are not here at the moment and they will
not bother me now I accidentally started
recording before so I did some things in
this room that I wasn't supposed to but
I know what I need to do because some
things seem to be reset anyway I put the
frog that I had in here and then I moved
this plan over and I already put the
rose that was on that table over on the
other one and I'm almost done with this
room what you need to do is you need to
make a mirror image into the other one
so nothing spooky happened that I missed
Isis accidentally I I dragged my entire
computer down here to South Carolina
with me so I accidentally forgot a few
things so I improvised what we're doing
just fine anyway so thank you very much
anyway continuing forward we got this um
we need to get we need eat this cake so
that there's no longer any here when you
- there's a piece of cake okay we got a
piece of cake we don't need to eat any
cake we can put this cake over here on
the table
exactly symmetrically - this one put
cake on the table okay there's white
bears on the right right
there's pink bears on the right right
the frog is on the chair that was
something I was pretty obvious the
paintings are different the paintings
are wrong how do I make them right
did that do it okay they look pretty
symmetrical there um sorry my I'm bad at
this and crossing my eyes trying to see
the differences
the notes on the wall can I rip that off
I need to take that oh I have a letter I
can put the other one up on the other
wall that might work oh those shells are
different hang on those shells are
different there we go okay got that and
put the note on the wall because I have
a letter here don't read no yes okay I'm
missing something else here there's got
to be wait maybe I did it no so locked
okay what am I missing here paintings
are right pink bear frog flowers on the
table are in the right orientation cakes
are facing the right way plants are
symmetrical roses white bears the
paintings are correct
the shelves are correct we know they're
not away hang on Han Han there's one
knot here these Reds are not supposed to
be here did that do it did that do it
can I get out here now please thank you
before something else tries to kill me
no okay more giant teddy bears trying to
kill me Oh tear-off nope did that do it
yes all right all right we can get out
of here but first I'm in what oh oh
sorry sorry mr. froggy I'll take you
with me but now the rooms aren't
symmetrical I just spit all over my
monitor what is wrong with me anyway
okay here we go
now I'm going to save so that I don't
miss anything else and then we can
continue moving forward ray the door has
opened
what have we got waiting for me over
here through the next door and let
nothing distract you what's gonna happen
Reed
my father and my mother didn't love me
so I X them I been in this house ever
since flower adorns the desk it's not
lit can i light it okay sings distracted
me
hey what happened what is it oh well you
got me good there okay I let something
distract me and that's what's in it okay
all right I'm truly excuse me that's
disgusting simply locate moving forward
and once we get into this room let
nothing distract me exactly this way and
through the door okay you need to read I
did it again no don't kill I did it
again how what did I do
how what did I do wrong
like most of the games I play what did I
do wrong
okay so I'm doing something wrong I
didn't let anything to drag me
what oh don't let anything distract me
in this room oh oh okay don't get me
don't catch me don't even stop to save
no shinies no books don't kill me
all right kill me that's pretty rough oh
oh that makes so much more sense in what
I was doing and what I was doing was
apparently stupid hooray yeah woosh nope
uh-uh no uh-uh
not doing nothing oh no oh no you didn't
he's hung oh no who's hungry
I don't know
hello something's on the other side I
wonder what listen closely look at door
open door let's just barge right in that
sounds smart yes really barge right in
ha ha it got me yep that was dumb don't
know what I was expecting I guess I was
expecting a giant monster to buy my head
off and I got exactly that oh no people
are here
hello hi Ryan and Daniel just walked in
again I met a room and there's a note on
the ground and all it says is he's
hungry I'm like yeah this is a door what
okay go go away go okay look at door
there's a viewing window the size of
your palm don't stick your hand in
listen closely you hear something big
crawling look through window you see
slimy black scales what do I do
there's no other option besides to
opening the damn door
can't let my frog go through this would
be horrific but yeah okay
the Frog is reluctant I would be to
force it in died froggy you were useful
to me and now you no longer are I'll
murder you horrific Lee oh it's so sad
I have to kill my froggy Oh
look through the window I see nothing
but blood I hear nothing
all right let's go in okay all right
okay it's just here dripping blood
that's good ah let's not go talking
though the froggy goes by me good
okay cat statue oh is nice what that cat
looked I'm a catcher cats at you real
cat okay kidding okay yeah you're so
clever
hey don't ignore me okay just let me
save before the coast of the Frog kills
me oh ah what the hell why why would you
do that I don't know I don't care I
don't know and I don't care I'm going up
who's that go where only one eye is open
what's that ring I don't know Oh No what
the hell is that
I don't wanna Oh oh my god Oh
Juana this is what I oh my god what I'm
going in okay
hi this is a hole big enough yeah let's
go
this is smart this is smartest yep what
I died it did it Munsch my bones what
the hell okay whatever it's gonna screw
that screw everything about that there
isn't one with just one eye open there's
a hole just big enough to crawl don't go
in both of them has closed eyes doesn't
make any sense and that one has big
giant eyes wide open okay let's try this
one probably gonna die again yeah I'm
dead okay I'm dead that was another
death trap thank you very much all right
I don't like this okay anyway go we're
only one eyes open they're all closed or
open oh wait a minute
maybe there's a ha ha ha ha ha ha oh
it's just a giant mouth again okay
oh it looked at me oh excuse all right
whatever
oh man oh that's what I was seeing
how's the tongue of whatever creature
was swallowing me whole why is that
there what the hell dad snake sounded
far runs don't want to this floor is
pretty quiet okay yes I'll say thank you
black cat stupid ass hold was that what
is that a toy soldier with a fake gun
somehow I don't believe that okay we're
going in this room here and it's awfully
quiet here why is it quiet I must ask
it's like unusually quiet okay
all right okay I'm making noise in this
room I guess I guess that's okay
plays a music box with 12 with 12 what I
don't know okay whatever the toy box it
won't open
I don't care which is diary okay let's
read your diet ix all the friends who
came to my house after that they were
all eaten by the house but it wasn't
enough okay am I being eaten by the
house this is why I'm here as is my
purpose in life probably a big glass
covered with nothing
who's that I saw that I think you can
run anything I got my webcam good
get back here thank you oh [ __ ] just
spilled water everywhere
towels don't let it get on the power
cables hello everybody we're still alive
where's the way I got the towel ah to
make sure it's not drip oh god damn it
everything's going wrong everybody it's
filled here I think I got most of it
ripping up Oh dad's fine okay we got it
we got it yes please thank you I've
destroyed a keyboard before by doing
that i whole whole team to help me out
here we're good we're good
I'm good yes please put it over there
away okay thank you
haha I might have been the best jump
scare ever what the hell is going on
over there okay all right we're back in
order everybody thank you for your
patience and understanding in this
endeavor
look I think it's time to end this
episode I can't really top that so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and thank you Ryan and yo thank you
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
Oh
but you're not
hiding
oh there we go